okay new game trying to remember what he
was playing oh yeah okay yeah he was
playing I'm gonna play a London I did a
little bit of preparation he sometimes
plays of London's white too
okay so we're gonna have I was expecting
d5 but we're gonna have a job on London
I'll play III
yeah my opponent has experience in this
from the light side so this will be
interesting I mean generally I think
this is fun to play and in rapid chess I
do to play h5 next if clockwise h5 then
ideas to bring the Knight to e5 and very
often white little Castle queenside a
block taking a lot of time ok h5 if
black plays c5 too early I'll have 95 on
4096 a very nice line
I'm not sure like the theoretical
standing I don't think h5 is like
considered to be the last move
I'm sure it's playable okay black wants
to play c5 play play 95 right away
remember I was doing this is another
opening work which I was preparing for
his Fiddler's okay and I remember
looking at like c5 and just playing very
kind of calmly no black were to go for
this stuff there's some eventual like
king b1 and chops with taking on on d5
d6 so I've I've had a very similar
position before in the tournament game
where I played Queen f3 to g3 I'm just
kind of appealing
she had this a few times in tournament
games
yeah the only waste too much time I'm
not sure if objectively this is the best
move but it's easy to play hey some day
92 c3 then later after three Qin hu g4
it could take time but in some sense
it's it's restrictive play if I play
Queen g3 there'll be a battery on the
diagonal
yeah with c6 Bishop f5 okay at some
point I might might play Bishop d3 I'm
debating whether to play it right away
or to castle first castling first may be
more flexible ship d3 right away also I
mean also just questions of Bishop
because takes takes all I think that
structure is reasonable for whites
there's Bishop efore but I went up on
let's play Bishop d3
yeah I think for each of us like our
likes red bishops aren't the most useful
pieces I'm not sure like if we trade who
this benefits maybe me cuz g4 will be
less exploitable wow he six you six is
interesting
no slightly unexpected I assume ideas to
take with e pawn and Queen g3 comes to
mind he moves like Bishop each you also
come to mind but I'm probably not
working so I'd want to leave the bishops
just stuck
so concerning Queenie - as well idea to
play f3g for because Queen g3 box of
Jeep on
and Queenie - this feels like I'm
wasting time also take away with square
from my knight but my knight I guess
stays to support efore
looking at c-54 black of corny - lucy
five that I can take and they've take
Cindy fives weaker okay Queenie to
influx will move I'm actually I'm
staying flexible I which sites a castle
on looking could be very safe on the
kingside but if I end up playing f3g for
that I want my work on each one to
support the file
I like these positions because like it's
easy to send out what the plan is like
just the stuff and then later attack and
sometimes it's still tricky in the
nuances yeah b5 this is one of the
drawbacks of Queenie - I don't have 92
but I was thinking that I still play f3
and if B 490 by 2 D 1 2 f2 I could even
like play a 4 to provoke before probably
no reason
if I get in g4 I just like to throw in
the trade but I think at some point
black will have to take strength in the
center and hopefully I can open up at
least one file on the kingside
there's also idea before 9a for because
c5 is kind of weak now actually after b5
the Knights tie-down so there's no
immediate 97 okay tix should leave my
knight on e5 a nice center actually the
abbey for 9a for it looks really
attractive the be 494 25 there's b3 idea
Brookes e1 and like c5 s a weak square
c6 us backwards pod so there's actually
a few approaches like I could play
positioning on the Queen side with rook
c1 and depending what Bach does too
or I could just play really aggressively
on the Kings side like g4 okay I'm
feeling better than the previous game
previous game I just feel like it around
the point after you opening and then
just misjudged 97 hopefully I'm
misjudging this position and still a
fight for sure 97 makes a lot of sense
now the palm stays defended black is I
don't know if Fox threatening to take
maybe but with Knights ft7 I can play g4
threatened to take there's no knight
takes h4 still defended that six never a
worry because Knight takes c6 so let's
play g4
calculating Knight takes e5 pawn Daisy
597 g4 I think that's all reasonable for
me and you know if ever block ever takes
I'm ready to play each five point h2 and
could be a very scary h-file attack so a
question here is do I take with Bishop
because that also looks reasonable
looks very reasonable because this is
blacks one main defender if I take this
bishop there is f6 and then probably
Bishop Bishop g3 there's e5
I mean both both lines look pretty nice
okay I guess with pawn take 97 here like
a fives a move or f6
but yeah I'd like that well am I scared
of only thing I'm scared of is f65 push
back for search takes takes e5 takes
takes Bishop g5 and then h5 ideas
castling queenside
I have six I also have Bishop g3 so I
have options and e5 and e5 know I think
after f6 Bishop f4 Black has to do
something about the tension if every
five I I'll take and play Bishop g5 and
they child should H over G file should
open let's go for this 97 I'll play f4
actually way it takes takes takes is g4
as well but d4 94 okay let's do this
well I guess there's takes and be for
about nine a four and then D for could
be a big nuts who takes first that's
slightly unexpected so I have the option
of taking then there's Intermezzo takes
h5 I mean also just taking back looks
quite reasonable
I'm trying to evaluate this because it's
it's pretty concrete takes takes takes
and then each five work a chain and then
Castle queenside I'll have ninety-two
ideas with her dg1 ideas down the pond
its Queen f6 so Queen a6 could ruin my
fun let's take back
you know soo bahk essentially has three
options can take can play off six or do
something else like 97 I mean he tries
my main kind of breakthrough idea thing
is in some lines each 5g5
nerve takes takes and like you 7d for
maybe black got some counterplay I'm
dreaming of some scenario where I have
pawns on D 45 and I play d5 then my
knight comes to g4 and then h5 that
could be really nice okay 97 immediately
so I should probably take on g7
hmm
takes on g7 King Diggs g7 Castle
queenside b49 a for it's kind of more
positional and put the King on b1 I mean
that makes sense to take
it also makes sense to Castle queenside
here there's corn a 525 immediately it's
kind of annoying because of I Castle
Queen 85 King b-1b for my Knights
trapped
Queen d2 is a move
Queen f2 also a moon also looking at
like castling 25 b3 it looks weakening
but I'm maybe logical or know that he
things and Knights what am I thinking
I'm b3 doesn't work and b3 doesn't work
I go for this looks wrong though
also aphorism of still a move but yeah
how am I dealing with the casting Queen
a5 Quincy - maybe
mmm Queen c2 casting Queen a 5 Queen C 2
B 495 theirs might be 6 ip6 kind of
annoying yeah my piece looks very
annoying
I mean they c5 I lose a pond and go for
counterplay hmm I mean what else to play
we need you to why was I rejecting Queen
d2 oh maybe because work h8y a rookie
Jada's come in so maybe queen f - we're
gonna have to 25 or each five right away
actually each hayver italy is
interesting a lot of moves to consider
I allow Queen g5 but then I just Castle
Rock Jiwon h5 and if Queen a5 I'm black
has kind of showed his hand I've aged
six or just Queen d2 let's play h5 yeah
my thoughts were kind of scattered there
like I just want a castle in King be one
but I don't think there is enough time
for it
initially was very husband to h5 because
Queen g5 just looks like such a nice
square but I think I would just castle
put rook down rook on G 1 okay I want
the play to be focused on the Kings side
also maybe the queen is exploitable like
some day get the night somewhere but
yeah time is becoming more relevant I
think that that position was a critical
moment had to spend some time and
hopefully the moves will be natural
coming up
I mean Queen a5 and Queen g5 are very
different when a5 will prevent me from
caste and Queen side and then I have a
choice what to do with a pawn tension
maybe I would play Queen h2 rook h8 so
flux will move wondering if I can
there's actually interesting possibility
to try and get away with castling not
sure if it works so to Castle Queen f -
Birkhoff lon
and then 92 I lose my a pawn still
hmm so that that's actually a very
similar situation our cage 8 was
probably good move Aquin h2 is
interesting ideas to play each six but
then Queen g5 could be very strong
another idea she very interesting ideas
a castle Queen a 5 and then h6 in sack
upon Queen h2 King g71 or rook h1 before
[Music]
they like Queen h7 roof lon so castling
h6 there's King h7 forecasting 25 h6 i
asking g8 q g8 looks really ugly I have
this still yeah f7 is gonna be a target
let's castle I think it works tactically
so I thought I counter play revolves
around f7 in the line after Queen
eighty-five h6 here Queen f2 will come
or quite a3 will come with tempo I'm not
sure which is better but it's black when
we need to defend and then I have time
for King B 1 so C 5 C 5 thematic h6
should always be considered I could just
take I could take on b5 to h6 takes
takes and queen up three your queen f2
are the moves that come to mind also
just taking
got to move a lot quicker like six takes
and if can be one he may be king be one
before 94 no looks slow but I think it's
useful and so many lines with like Queen
g5 won't be checked 25 on hit a 2 pond
and I get in before I'm baking on that
a4 and then having the c5 square it
might lead to me sacking a pawn but I
shouldn't give me a nice play like for
example before here I'll say takes takes
Queen 85-95 takes takes takes there's 25
an end and then a black should be in big
trouble there
yeah like ever takes and I'll have a bit
more access to the e5 square an idea
would be nice c5 and Queen e5 because
there's some distant line where if this
stuff happens and black plays Queen f6 I
have h6 tactics yeah it's the nice thing
about having the pawn I'm just kind of
staying here black always has to watch
out for h6
and yeah the balls in Black's courts has
to do something about c5 rook CA may be
expected rook c8 maybe I just play
simple like what got fun okay so I have
the double double D pawns Queen g5
interesting yeah I move on while the
players might see five I see five takes
takes not entirely sure and if this
there's Knight f6 maybe Rick HG 1 and
then Knight c5 looks reasonable
it's interestingly not a six rook hg1
will just be like very restrictive and
the Queen's a bit stuck and on g5 in
that line also ideas of like 95 Queen
takes six cuz tactics even I see five or
takes off 7h Eric HFE okay interesting
it's hard to remove the Queen I could
take on in taking on g6 looks attractive
and then I'd see five
and this looks very reasonable those of
politics I win the pawn if Queen takes I
denied c5 with pressure and then if we
trade there's something games where C
pawn has passed and all their lines a
lot of Queen e5 check
now the H house opens of wreckage five
ideas I'm neither 6i of g5
I'm calculating night of 6g 597 I assume
is something like the very least work h6
takes in Queen each to double thread of
taking in the nur of g1 so maybe Knight
takes e5 expected I mean but I gots to
defend against the threat if 48 I take
and Queenie 5 + f6 is force and I just
win upon open I lose upon but then King
a one I have initiative that's probably
preferable for white because the rook is
tied down to d5 and the King's just
weaker than mine so it takes you 5 takes
e5 also like you're consider it takes
you 525 immediately probably not good
though I want to keep this defended
at some point even g5i dg5 to discourage
f6 so 25 will be a bit more lethal
now g5 there's this move but then this
move okay that's getting interesting g5
LG if I could be very strong to rely on
intuition now 25 first of six blocks
defending g5 has to be played
oh there's rook each no work H a queen
bee five yeah so I basically have a
double threat of Queen e5 which should
just went on a spot as well as like rook
f6 or h6 and idea would be after Queen
takes g5 I think I just moved back and
then this these threats are very hard to
stop
and meanwhile everything defended okay
so just to calculate precisely what was
black doing there I'm looking for a
possibilities - there's also this and
then this idea wreckage seven or rook g1
maybe that's better
let's start with Rick h6 that's Queen g5
only move Queen each - Queen eh - Rick
har of t1 Oh Queen dings do you want oh
that doesn't work okay so Rick h1 is a
back-up plan which better work also work
h2 choices choices maybe Rick h2 ideas
like Queen move somewhere I have queen
g4 with nice mate
just making sure I have plenty of time
even though it doesn't look like it
triple checking yet let's play rock h2
cuz yep with rook h1 maybe there is like
Queenie 7 or Queen de and the King runs
probably not though no there's never
mind yeah there's winds and not line too
but yeah this is this is unsolvable and
I'm either mating or winning the Queen
or both
so yeah the King side attack somehow
crashed through g5 was nice smooth in
chief I was uh he moved to to make
things work yeah interesting game ok got
revenge but two interesting games I
would like to put this on I'd like to
put both games on YouTube maybe I'll
split it up maybe I'll divide it one
video each but yeah this is this was
different
GG